en arcticle avec une glaciologue
documentaire exclusif pour notre chaîne
et réalisé par Pierre
dugofson un film vous venez de le voir
tourner sur l'archipel de zvalbard en
Arctique proche du Pôle Nord une région
qui se réchauffe 6 à 7 fois plus vite
que le reste de la planète là aussi où
la glaciologue française Idy svestre
observe depuis des années le recul des
glaciers avec pour conséquence imparable
la montée des EAU peut-on encore espérer
enrayer phénomène aux allures
dramatiques directement lié au
dérèglement climatiques et bien nous
allons en débattre maintenant avec nos
invités présents sur ce plateau de
dbadoc et Edie Sevestre est avec nous
bienvenue c'est la magie de télévision
on vient de vous quitter avec ce film on
vous retrouve ici même sur ce plateau
plus chaud ici hein vous êtes une
glaciologue de renommée internationale
nous vous avons donc suivi tout au long
de ce film vous êtes entre autres
membres du programme de surveillance et
d'évaluation de l'article et enseignante
à l'université de valbarde la plus
secentrionale qui soit c'est en Norvège
on verra une carte tout à l'heure votre
dernier ouvrage a pour titre sentinelle
du climat publié aux éditions harur
Colin c'est Yannick jado est également
avec nous bienvenue à vous Yannick jado
vous étiez le candidat Europe Écologie
Les Verts à l'occasion de l'élection
présidentielle de
2022 vous êtes aujourd'hui sénateur
Europe Écologie les vers de Paris vous
avez été pendant 14 ans députés
européens sous la même étiquette hein
d'ailleurs et votre dernier ouvrage
s'intitule lui faire face le défi du
siècle c'est un ouvrage publié aux
éditions Les petit matin une carte je
vous l'avais promis pour situer Svalbard
on été tourné à deux en deux fois hein
ce ce film hein c'est une première fois
je crois c'est au printemps 2022 et
ensuite on est à l'automne 2022 c'est
bien ça ex sont des périodes assez
magiques oui on est dans la transition
jour nuit nuit 24h/ 24 jours 24 he sur
24 et donc pour des réalisateurs
vraiment des périodes on a des lumières
extraordinaires ouais on l'a vu hein
d'ailleurs avec ces très belles images
filmées par Pierre dugovson valbard donc
dans à l'intérieur du cercle po arctique
là où
euh cette région ser réchauffe 6 à 7
fois plus vite que que la planète on va
venir tout de suite c'est donc un
archipel norvégien et c'est la base
avancée de recherche enarti en réalité
vous y avez été doctorante pendant 4 ans
la première fois vous y étiz sur place
c'est en 2008 et les choses on l'a vu
ont bien changé he au fur à mesure que
vous y allez hein ouais c'est vraiment
cataclyme que les changements là-bas il
faut s'imaginer que sur terre
globalement les températures ont gagné
1,1 1,2 degr au valbard c'est 6 à 7
degrés d'augmentation de température
alors pourquoi 6 à 7 fois
ouais c'est une très bonne question plus
de réchauffement que sur d'autres les
autres régions du monde pourquoi en fait
on se rend compte vraiment que les
régions de neige et de glace sont les
régions qui se réchauffent le plus vite
sur terre parce que quand on regarde des
images on voit que ces surfaces sont
très blanches et ces surfaces plus elles
sont blanches plus elles vont renvo
voyez la chaleur du soleil en direction
de l'espace c'est comme quand on a une
maison qui est peinte en blanc ou quand
on a un t-shirt blanc pendant l'été on a
un peu moins chaud et ben ces régionsl
puisqu'elles ont beaucoup de glace elles
sont un petit peu plus froides le
problème c'est que cette glace elle se
réchauffe très vite à cause de
l'augmentation des températures donc
elle disparaît à la place de surface
blanche qu'est-ce qu'on a on a un océan
qui lui va être beaucoup plus foncé si
la banquise disparaît lorsque les
glaciers se retirent on a des roches qui
elles aussi sont beaucoup plus foncées
en couleur donc c'est assez simple le
fait que l'Arctique s'assombrisse avec
la perte de la glace ça fait que
l'Arctique absorbe beaucoup plus de
chaleur et donc ça explique pourquoi le
zvalbard en particulier cet archipel
aujourd'hui se réchauffe si à 7 fois
plus vite que le reste de la planète
vous avez eu l'occasion de vous y rendre
dans cette région du monde non
malheureusement non est-ce que vous avez
été sur l'un des pôles parce que si j'ai
bien appris mal le son 90 % des glaces
ne se trouvent pas en Arctique mais sur
l'autre pôle le Pôle Sud en Antarctique
non j'ai pas eu la j'ai pas eu le prix
privilège d'aller d'aller voir ces
régions magnifiques en revanche j'ai
vécu au Bangladesh et vous allez dire le
Bangladesh quel rapport entre l'Arctique
l'Antarctique les glaciers ben en fait
le Bangladesh comme l'Inde comme la
Chine
vivent réellement de du régime de fonde
des glaciers de l'Himalaya et que la
question des glaciers la question de la
glace en général elle concerne en fait
la planète entière
vous avez parlé l'élévation du niveau de
la mer c'est évidemment une des
conséquences absolument dramatiques de
la fonte des glacesir il faut voir que
beaucoup beaucoup des milliards de
personnes dans le monde vivent du régime
des glaces et que par exemple la fonte
des glaciers dans leshalayas aura des
conséquences absolument dramatiques pour
la sécurité alimentaire en Inde au
Bangladesh en Chine là où il y a
aujourd'hui quasiment la moitié de la
population mondiale
donc on est sur un régime global qui est
en train de s'affaisser de s'effondrer
et dont on perçoit encore aujourd'hui y
compris parce que c'est tellement
anxiogène que se le dire c'est déjà
flippant c'est que on est en train de
changer totalement notre système mondial
notre système de climat d'eau de
sécurité alimentaire et que si on n'agit
pas on va vers le chaos d'ailleurs
c'était pas en artique que vous étiez
récemment mais mais en Colombie pour
peut-être donner suite à ce qu'on a vu
dans dans ce film c'était peut-être
suite à une demande d'association
colombienne he c'est ce qu'on a vu dans
dans ce document vous y êtes rendu il y
a assez peu de temps pour y découvrir
quoi ouais je reviens tout juste là de
Colombie en fait en Colombie il y a des
glaciers alors ça peut paraître
complètement fou mais il y a des
montagnes jusqu'à 5000 m d'altitude en
Colombie donc l'altitude c'est vraiment
ce qui permet lorsqu'il y a des
précipitations qu'ell tombent sous forme
de neige et donc de créer des glaciers
et il y a 70 petits glaciers posés sur
les montagnes de Colombie il y a un
glaciologue local tout seul qui doit
surveiller ses glaciers en fait ils sont
cruciaux comme l'a très bien dit Yannick
en fait ces glaciers dans Colombie ce
sont parmi les meilleurs château d'eau
que l'on a dans ces montagnes en période
sèche et chaude lorsqu'on a plus de
pluie et ben l'eau elle va venir d'où
elle va venir de la fondte de la neige
de la fondte de la glace et en Colombie
on se rend compte qu'il y a toute une
agriculture qui en dépend vous parliez
très bien de la sécurité alimentaire
c'est le café en l'occurrence exactement
beaucoup beaucoup la la la la les pommes
de terre aussi une agriculture de
subsistance aussi qui dépend de ces
glaciers et n'oublions pas ça c'est
crucial l'importance culturelle aussi de
ces glaciers he c'est vrai que chez nous
en France on est très fier quand même
d'avoir des glaciers dans les Pyrénées
dans les Alpes et ben en Colombie aussi
il y a une immense fierté à avoir encore
des glaciers dans ces régions et c'est
des glaciers qui ont une importance
énorme pour les communautés autochtones
alors on va voir si j'ai bien appris mal
leçon he c'est 1 % des glaciers se situe
aujourd'hui en montagne mais 80 % 99 %
de la glace se situe euh soit au Pôle
Nord soit au pôle Sud et 90 % des glaces
se trouvent plutôt au pôle Sud en
Antarctique est-ce qu'on observe le même
phénomène que celui qui est décrit ici
du côté arctique en Antarctique
justement là où se trouve l'essentiel
des glaces sur la planète ouais alors
pendant longtemps et si on vient au tout
premier rapport du GC dat du début des
années 90 on avait vraiment une mauvaise
idée de ce qui se passait en Antarctique
c'est très loin c'est très cher d'aller
mener des expéditions là-bas aujourd'hui
on sait très clairement ce qui se passe
en Antarctique l'Antarctique se
réchauffe deux fois plus vite que le
reste de la planète l'Arctique c'est
plus trois à quatre fois mais
l'Antarctique comme vous l'avez très
bien dit contient beaucoup plus de glace
pour vous donner une petite idée si
l'Arctique perdait sa glace si le
Groenland perdait sa glace c'est 6 à 7 m
d'augmentation du niveau des mers
partout sur terre donc le bangladesch
c'est vite vu hein c'est 80 90 % du
territoire l'antar artique contient
beaucoup plus de glace si l'Antarctique
perdait sa glace c'est 58 m d'élévation
du niveau des mers partout sur terre et
un dernier chiffre aujourd'hui entre 0
et 10 m d'altitude il y a 1 milliard de
personnes sur terre et donc je suis tout
à fait d'accord tout le monde est
concerné par la hausse du niveau des mer
qu'on habite au bord de la mer ou pas
c'est nos infrastructures c'est nos
ports c'est notre agriculture c'est des
déplacements de population ça ça se
prépare tout de suite hein l'élévation
du niveau des mers donc il faut il faut
qu'on cravage parce que ça nous ça n on
va droit dedans quoi alors ça se prépare
tout de suite oui réellement ça se
prépare en ce moment au moment où nous
parlons ça continue à se préparer non
non malheureusement la science est là
depuis longtemps ou depuis des décennies
maintenant la science nous dit étape
après étape voilà ce qui va nous arriver
euh et on a été très longtemps dans le
dénis en réalité
collectivement malgré la science malgré
ce que nous nous pouvions dire faire et
c'était même il y a encore 10 ans dans
les négociations internationales sur le
climat on parlait de la science et on
parlait des générations futures moi
j'étais pendant longtemps directeur des
campagnes de Greenpeace ou le
dérèglement climatique c'était aussi les
ours blancs quand on parlait d'épauulle
euh et aujourd'hui en fait quand on
parle de dérèglement climatique on parle
de sa maison on parle des 70 % de
logement notamment dans les quartiers
populaire où les gens étouffent c'est la
précarité énergétique c'est
l'agriculture qui sait plus bien comment
se situer par rapport à à ces
changements météorologiques liés au
dérèglements climatiques c'est les
catastrophes qu'on voit absolument
partout et on a l'impression qu'en fait
on est passé comme si on était passé
d'un régime climatique un peu près
stable il y a pas de dérèglement
climatique ça va venir mais on a le
temps à un autre régime stable qui
serait le dérèglement climatique comme
si on était pas à devoir courir
aujourd'hui après chaque Dième de
réchauffement de la planète comme si on
n était pas simplement au début du chaos
mais qu'on était dans un régime de chaos
voilà c'est ça le dérèglement climatique
on a d'autres formes de dénis vous voyez
bien que partout regardez on est on a
frollé les températures de 45° en
Amérique latine ces dernières semaines
et on n'est pas encore en été hein 45°r
sont des records euh y compris en
Argentine
qui a élu un
climatoceptique qui dit c'est totalement
il le dit avec son vocabulaire d'une
grossièreté d'une vulgarité absolue qui
dit le dérèglement climatique ça existe
pas c'est des conneries pour les
scientifiques gauchistes voilà c'est
comme ça qu' parle du dérèglement
climatique on a partout en Europe et
dans le reste du monde une extrême
droite une droite qui viennent
directement aujourd'hui sur le dénis du
dérèglement climatique c'estd qu'au fond
c'estes défi
extraordinaires qu'on a devant nous et
ben pour pas s'emmerder ils le disent un
peu comme ça pour pas s'embêter avec ces
défis là on les met complètement de côté
et puis il y a une troisième forme de
déis qui est le solutionnisme
technologique c'estd qu'au fond on a un
problème avec le transport aérien vous
inquiétez pas en 2060 il y aura l'avion
vert on a un problème de transport au
quotidien plutôt que de faire des
transports collectifs on va remplacer
des voitures thermiques par des SUV
électriques on a un problème
d'alimentation d'électricité vous
inquiétez pas dans 20 ans il y aura de
nouveaux réacteurs nucléire donc on
essaie de
fuir la transformation de nos habitudes
c'est pas simple on doit changer toutes
et tous et puis surtout nos
gouvernements
reconnaissons-le évite refuse de taper
les rentes les lobbyes qui aujourd'hui
nous empêchent d'avancer on parle de
l'article on est est dans le cynisme
absolu en fait la fonte totale de la
banquise c'est une opportunité
extraordinaire pour aller chercher un
peu plus de pétrole là où on pouvait pas
y aller c'està dire que la banquise
disparaît les glaciers fondent à cause
du pétrole et c'est une opportunité pour
être encore plus addictif au pétrole
tout ça est dingue donc il va falloir
une sacrée rupture quand même vousz de
nous le dire he les scientifiques nous
alertent depuis des années des des
années des années vous êtes une
scientifique vous vous définissez comme
une sentinelle du climat he j'ai souvent
lu ça vous faites partie de de celle qui
alerte qui continue d'alerter hein vous
éitez tout votre cœur d'ailleurs tout
votre expérience qui commence à se
construire aussi hein au cours des des
années mais on a le sentiment que les
choses ne se passent pas entre
responsablebl politique et scientifique
que le courant ne passe
pas comment vous avez envie de réagir à
ce que vient de dire Yannick jado par
exemple moi je suis d'accord sur
énormément de pointsou vous voulez
rester dans votre rôle de simplement de
sentinelle en disant attention ou est-ce
qu'il y a pas un moment où il faut c'est
notre rôle principal faut être plus
présent quand on est scientifique c'est
clair on est là d'abord pour informer et
pour faire des recommandations moi je
vois au conseil de l'article donc là où
je travaille on a une façon de
fonctionner qui est vraiment
intéressante on est un peu un Minic un
anogc qui est le groupement
intergouvernemental des experts sur le
climat qui publie vous savez ses grands
rapports toutes les quelques années au
niveau de l'article intéressant comment
fonctionne en fait les gouvernements
viennent vers nous ou les scientifiques
avec des questions comment est-ce que le
changement climatique va impacter nos
populations la santé humaine et cetera
et cetera et c'est à nous ensuite nous
notre groupe de travail on travaille
avec à peu près 800 experts
scientifiques d'arriver à produire des
rapports pour répondre à leurs questions
donc il y a en quelque sorte une attente
des gouvernement vous répondez aux
questions et vous faites aussi des
préconisations c'est ce que vous dites
hein dans ce film exactementon et alors
là où ça bloque avec les responsables
politiques il y a des sujets où
semble-t-il les choses peuent avancer
c'est ce que vous dites aussi santé
publique santé publique biodiversité
exactement mais énergie fossile on
avance pas du tout euh c'est ce que vous
dites aussi c'est exactement ça oui oui
alors on le voit il y a 7 millions
d'habitants dans l'artile donc c'est
quand même une bonne population et cette
population subit directement au cœur de
sa santé hein les effets du changement
climatique on voit notamment que les
glaces ont emmagasiné énormément de
mercure alors là on va parler de sujets
un peu brutaux plus on brle d'énergie
fossile plus on amet de mercure ce
mercure en fait il arrive va s'enterrer
à se se stocker dans les glaces
malheureusement on est en train de les
perdre toutes ces glaces dans l'Artique
et donc ce mercure est remobilisé et ça
impacte directement les populations donc
là quand on dit au pays de l'Arctique
attention vous et vos populations sont
en train de subir l'impact du mercure la
réaction elle est très rapide pas que
dans l'article voir carrément au-delà
donc là ça marche là on est content voir
il y a des grandes conventions comme la
convention mini Mata qui est mise en
place le souci c'est quand on touche à
des sujets comme voilà l'exploitation du
gaz du pétrole le oui parce que les pays
de l'Artique alors on a le grenlande on
a la Finlande la Norvège la Norvège
c'est un bon exemple sur les énergies
fossiles il y a encore énormément de
réserves fossiles au large de la Norvège
il y a des projets on nous en annonce
d'ailleurs assez fréquemment faut juste
pasoucher à un moment donné enfin on
peut pas à la fois être aussi bien
informé sur le chaos vers lequel on va
la température du globe moi quand je
fait on nous dit toujours qu type de
comparaison vous pouvez faire pour que
les gens se rendent compte c'est
toujours très compliqué parce qu'on se
dit ouais 2 degrés de réchauffement
climatique si c'est en moyenne au fond
qu'est-ce que ça change dans nos vies
alors on voit bien qu'en fait c'est pas
du réchauffement linéaire c'est du
dérèglement c'est du chos c'est de
l'instabilité moi je compare à la
température
humaine quand on est à
39° au fond on n pas bien mais on
continue quand on est à 41 ce qui ce
vers quoi on va plus 4°gr au fond dans
nos régions à nous
euh c'est nos organes qui commencent à
déconner complètement qui commencent à
se dérégler complètement et c'est nos
organes au niveau climatique c'est son
l'épaule c'est nos grandes forêts c'est
l'océan c'est les courants marins c'est
les courants d'air et donc au fond on
est en train on FO on on est en train de
se dérégler compltement et là on a
quelque chose qui qui ne va plus c'est
que on voit la COP qui arrive qui
démarre aprèsdemain la COP 28 qui
démarre à Dubaï on n'arrive pas à parler
des énergies fossiles comme ça je dire
on sait que c'est la principale le
principale cause de émissions de gaz à
effet de serre du dérèglement cl on
narrive pas à dire comment on sort des
énergies fossiles on sait que tout ce
qui est emmagasiné F toucher c'est une
folie faut plus y toucher et il va
falloir arrêter une partie des de
l'exploitation pétrolière et gazière qui
a déjà commencé et à la place de ça on a
il y a une enquête qui est sortie dans
les journaux mondiaux il y a quelques il
y a quelques jours on a près de 400
bombes climatiques de gisement
pétroliers y compris en projet qu'on
continue à financer avec de l'argent
public que nos banques dans lesquelles
on met nos économies Contin continu à
financer là encore si on n'est pas
capable collectivement d'avoir ce qu'on
appelle un traité de non prolifération
des l'explit des énergies faussi on
arrête et ben on on ça sera la
catastrophe pour nous donc ça très
concrètement ça fait partie de vos
préconisations plus aucun projet dans
cette régioncernant les énergies Foss al
pas dans cette région franchement sur la
planète entière il faut il faut savoir
aujourd'huiû voilà il y a des réalités
physiques en fait qui sont liées à ce
changement climatique avec lesquels on
peut pas négocier aujourd'hui on sait
que si on ouvre un nouveau gisement de
gaz ou de pétrole ou si on va chercher
encore plus de charbon pour le brûler on
va pulvériser des seils de température
notamment le seil des 1,5°r
d'augmentation de température ce soil il
est pas du tout tiré d'un chapeau il a
une vraie réalité physique derrière on
sait que si on franchit les
1,5°r d'augmentation globale donc
partout sur terre de la température nous
ce que l'on observe dans les glaces
c'est que le Grenland va commencer à
s'effondrer de façon irréversible donc
on aura 6 à 7 m d'augmentation du niveau
des mers donc là on sera sur un point de
non retour on sera sur un point de non
retour c'est exactement cette notion là
la notion de point de nonretour d'accord
l'ouest dans l'Antarctique aussi 4 à 5 m
d'élévation du niveau des mers les
glaciers de montagne chez nous on peut
leur dire à faut se rendre compte queil
y a 1 milliard de gens qui sont
directement impactés 1 milliard de gens
qui vivent sur nos côtes vous rendez
compte les on est on a un débat
totalement hallucinant aujourd'hui dans
nos parlements sur l'immigration là en
terme de migration on est dans une zone
qu'on Nimagine même pas en fait ouais
ouais exactement et dans les 17
prochaines années c'est 87 millions de
personnes qui vont être concernées don
juste dans les 17 prochaines années sur
Terre par le fait que le niveau de la
mer augmente et en cas de tempête de
précipitation très intense ces
personnesl vont se retrouver les pieds
dans l'eau et person on parle de New
York Shanghai là voilà pour des grandes
grande ville aussi he par exemple ça ça
pour un peu illustrer no propoui on
parle de Bandon Le Havre la Roch
exctement le nord de la France c'est
chez nous directement la Camargue la
Camargue ces populations là elles vont
pas aller habiter dans des déserts elles
vont aller habiter dans des endroits
dans des pays suffisamment Sécur dans
des endroits où on peut s'établir
s'installer développer sa famille en
bonne santé il va falloir vraiment
réfléchir très sérieusement à qu'est-ce
qu'on fait de ces populations qui vont
se déplacer ouiou Yanni jadou vient de
prononcer le mot de traiter de non
prolifération pour illustrer vos propos
hein pour dire stop en fait au énergies
FA
bon c'est le lobbying industriel là qui
est-ce que ce sont les responsables
gouvernementaux qui ne mettent pas ce
type de traité en place qui n'arrivent
pas à se mettre d'accord à l'échelle de
la planète ou c'est pas eux qui font la
loi et ce sont les lobbyistes
industriels les acteurs industriels de
secteur qui font que les choses ne
peuvent pas se faire dans ce sensl je
suis curieuse de voir su cuux d'IR vot
en tout cas ben je peux vous parler de
la COP 28 qu'on est en train de préparer
qui est déjà en préparation depuis des
mois et des semaines euh ça va être très
compliqué moi la première je me souviens
à quelques mois je disais que c'était
plutôt positif finalement qu'on a une
COP une conférence du climat dans un
pays pétroggazier voilà c'est important
qu'on garde le dialogue ouvert je pense
que j'étais naïve mais à un point
vraiment stratosphérique là il y a une
étude qui est sortie de la BBC hier ou
avant-hier qui nous explique que
finalement le docteur sultan alphabert
qui est le président de la COP 28 cette
année qui est quand même le CEO he de
adnoc qui est une grosse industrie
pétrgazière le le PDG voilà qui souhaite
profiter de la COP 28 pour signer des
contrats pour créer de nouvelles
opportunités business pour les énergie
fossile c'est le bonde à l'envers qui
vous savez on est euh il y a peu de
moments dans la vie vous savez c'est un
peu la la fable de la grenouille vous
savez si vous voulez ébouillanter une
grenouille si vous la mettez dans l'eau
chaude elle sort
elle s'éjectjecte pour survivre mais si
vous la mettez dans l'eau froide et que
vous
montez vraiment très très
progressivement la température en fait
elle se neutralise elle voilà et puis un
moment doné elle finit ébouillantter
c'est ça notre situation est-ce qu'on
est capable au fond d'avoir un moment où
on dit stop on change de modèle est-ce
que notre modèle est si bienveillant
fraternel juste que respectueux de la
nature et de nous-même qui faille
absolument garder ce modèle et nier ce
qui est en train de se passer je ne
crois pas donc il faut qu'on arrive et
ça c'est notre responsabilité aussi
c'est la responsabilité des entreprises
c'est la responsabilité des syndicats
c'est la responsabilité des citoyens des
artistes de tout le monde de dire au
fond si on sort du pétrole est-ce qu'on
rentre dans un monde horrible ou pas
est-ce que c'est ce que disent les
experts scientifiques multiplié par 3
les énergies renouvelables est-ce que
c'est une catastrophe je crois pas
est-ce que agir sur nos logements les
isolés est-ce que c'est une catastrophe
non il y aura moins de pauvre
énergétique l'hiver moins de gens qui
suffoquent l'été donc tout ça crée de
l'emploi ça crée de l'activité
économique ça crée du bien-être est-ce
que changer notre modèle agricole pour
avoir plus d'alimentation de qualité
moins de destruction de l'Amazonie pour
faire du soja qui alimente nos élevages
industriels est-ce que c'est allé vers
le mal ou est-ce que c'est allé vers le
bien donc au fond à un moment donné il
faut qu'on ait des responsables
politiques nous le sommes nous le
faisons à l'échelle de ce que nous
pouvons faire nous écologistes mais des
responsables politiques qui n'ai pas
peur de ce que certains économistes
appellent le moment P Harbour c'est
Lester BR qui c'est qu'au fond comme les
États-Unis quand il l'attaque de pbour
ils sont sortis du dénis qui pouvait
être isolé de la guerre et ils ont
mobilisé toute leur société pour faire
face à la guerre et là on a une guerre
du climat c'est pas le moment de signer
des armistices avec les lobes exaement
quelle image vous en avez des
responsables
politiques alors j'ai la j'ai lu un
portrait de vous dans dans dans le
quotidien Libération ou vous étiez pas
convaincu du tout par l'implication
politique finalement alors non ça dépend
lesquels j'ai la chance de ouais
vraiment parce qu'il y a pas les
politiques exactement j'ai la chance de
rencontrer beaucoup d'élus de terrain un
de petite commune rural ou urbaine c'est
assez extraordinaire de voir à quel
point les choses bougent hein je pense
que ces personnes bah comme vous hein se
rendre bien compte que si on parle pas
du CL eu ces élus ils le sentent le
danger ouais ils le perçoivent pour leur
concitoyens très con c'est ça je pense
que le lien avec les concitoyens est
beaucoup plus fort et pour moi je suis
convaincu que le changement la lutte
contre le changement climatique et
l'érosion de la biodiversité elle sera
locale ou elle ne se fera pas après on a
besoin bien sûr des grandes instances
politiques pour mettre en place des
règlementations que nous avons évoqué
ensemble pour le moins tout à fait mais
mais c'est vrai qu'il y a énormément de
de d'envie de motivation de mobilisation
des élus de terrain après on a vraiment
besoin jusqu'au plus haut niveau que de
l'État que que les choses bougent oui
oui tout à l'heure vous avez des
solutions scientifiqu le progrès
scientifique les progrès scientifiques
pourrai en partie enrayer le phénomène
dont nous parlons aujourd'hui est-ce que
vous croyez vous voyez des solutions
scientifiques vous capable vous n'avez
pas l'air d'y croire de
trop vous vous allez répond scientifique
ou technologique technologique par
scientifique oui oui les deux sont liés
bien sûr on est d'accord alors c'est
unciers très concrètement par rapport à
ce qu'on a vu là par exemple j'ai vu
qu'en Italie on pit certains essayent de
bâcher des glaciers pour les prés av un
temps soit peu mais ça a pas l'air
d'être une bonne solution parce que ça
libère des fibres qui après vont aller
dans des rivières et cetera bon il y a
il y a des solutions quand même
technologiques qui sont devant nous et
qui pourraient quand même nous donner un
petit rayon de soleil par rapport à tout
ce qu'on vient de se dire là alors ce
qui est crucial déjà c'est que on y
arrivera pas sans sobriété on y arrivera
pas sans des écosystèmes qui sont en
pleine santé que ce soit les océans les
prairies les forêts on a vraiment besoin
des écosystèmes qui marchent ça en
quelque sorte sont les meilleures
technologies naturelles qui nous permett
de lutter contre le changement
climatique ensuite on se rend de plus en
plus compte qu'on aura certainement
besoin d'une partie de ce qu'on appelle
la géoingénierie alors énorme prudence
sur ce sujet-là vraiment faire très très
attention on se rend compte que plus le
permaaprose donc ce sol jeelé en il
s'agit de modifier le climat alors oui
alors en fait il y a deux catégories de
géoingéerie il y en a une qui vise à
essayer de d'attraper le carbone
d'attraper le CO2 et le méthane et de
l'enfouir c'est une technologie qui
marche pas du tout à à l'échelle dont on
a besoin aujourd'hui qui coûte encore
très cher si on veut complètement
compenser nos émissions de gaz effet
grâce à cette technologie ça nous
demanderait tellement d'électricité que
c'est l'équivalent de la consommation
mondiale d'électricité aujourd'hui donc
pour l'instant on y'y est pas il y a
d'autres mais on va en avoir besoin
d'une petite partie de cette technologie
c'est sûr l'autre partie qui est très
flippante c'est la manipulation du
climat et là notamment il y a beaucoup
de start-up notamment une qui s'appelle
make sunsets qui est aux États-Unis qui
m'ont blacklisté je pense euh qui vise à
rejeter des particules de souffre dans
la stratosphère alors en fait les
volcans font ça très bien de façon
minime mais lorsqu'on on plâtre notre
stratosphère de particules en fait ça
bloque une partie du rayonnement solaire
sur terre je pense que ces personnesl
n'ont pas tout à fait compris que le
problème c'était les énergies fossiles
pas le soleil le soleil on en a encore
plutôt pas mal besoin je pense que les
agriculteurs seront les premiers à dire
que on aimerait bien avoir un peu
d'énergie du soleil le souci de ces
technologie c'est qu'on peut le faire d
aujourd'hui on peut appuyer sur un
bouton et le faire le problème il est
multiple c'est qu'on perturbe le cycle
de l'eau qu'on acidifie encore plus les
pluies les océans et qu'on risque aussi
de mettre notre climat sous perfusion
c'est-à-dire que chaque année on va
devoir balancer ces particules dans la
stratosphère et on sait jamais s'il a
une guerre mondiale s'il y a des
problèmes économiques et qu'une année on
peut plus le faire on peut se taper une
augmentation de température de plusieurs
degrés en quelques mois à peine donc ça
c'est terrible faire très attention je
vous ai coupé tout à l'heure non pas
pour revenir sur ces apports potentiels
technologiqu potentiel vous avez pas
l'air convaincu tout à l'heure c'est
pour ça mais moi je suis pour je suis
pour l'innovation je suis pour la
recherche scientifique on a des enjeux
majeurs par exemple dans le stockage de
l'électricité on a des enjeux majeurs
d'innovation pour que notre transition
énergétique qui va reposer sur
l'électricité se traduise pas par une
nouvelle forme d'extractivisme dans les
pays du Sud on a remplacé le pétrole et
les mines classiques par de nouvell un
nouvel extractivisme avec un quand on va
chercher le cobalt le lithium et tout ça
dans certains pays c'est une catastrophe
écologique et sociale donc si c'est pour
reproduire en permanence le même système
qui explose les limites de la planète
mais en disant il y aura une solution on
va rien changer mais il y aura une
solution technologique qui nous
permettra de conserver notre système tel
qu'il existe c'est abérrant ça quand
vous avez aujourd'hui dans les forts
dans les champs des paysans ou des
forestiers qui sont en train à la fois
d'utiliser Internet pour se renseigner
en
Australie en Norvège ou au Burkina Faso
comment on adapte telle plante c'est de
l'innovation pour faire en sorte qu'en
fait notre agriculture reste paysane et
qu'elle soit
agroécologique quand on je l'ai dit on
fait de la recherche sur le stockage
d'électricité et à mon avis ça viendra
vite c'est une formidable avancer pour
passer pour sortir du
charbon du
pétrole pour aller vers les énergies
renouvelable de manière extrêmement
forte donc au fond on a besoin
d'ingénierie on a besoin d'innovation
mais attention parce que à la fin on
finit avec Elon Musk et on se dit qu'on
va recréer les conditions de la terre
sur Mars je veux dire vous finissez
parfaitement votre votre doc en disant
fond c'est le beau qu'on doit défendre
l'enjeu pour nous c'est pas de sauver la
planète la planète elle se sbrasse en
nous l'enjeu pour nous si on veut sauver
l'humanité et le vivant non humain en
fait c'est d'aimer la planète c'est
d'aimer la nature c'est d'aimer une
alimentation de qualité c'est de pas se
satisfaire qu'on a cherché ou qu'on
brûle du du charbon en Chine pour
consommer n'importe quoi chez nous moi
je pourquoi j'aime l'éolien vous savez
les gens ils disent on aime on aime pas
il y a ce grand déb pas seulement parce
que vous êtes Picard d'origine alors non
mais oui mais c'est mais pourquoi parce
que fond c'est aussi ce dont on a besoin
on le produit à côté on doit assumer moi
pourquoi je suis pour la relocalisation
d'une partie de nos industries
polluantes c'est pour qu'on se rende
compte aussi de l'empreinte de nos modes
de vie et on peut être plus sobre la
sobriété c'est éviter la pénurie c'est
éviter le gaspillage et la pénurie c'est
pas demander aux gens qui ont pas de
moyens d'en avoir encore moins les ceux
qui sont les populations vulnérables
dans le monde et dans notre société ça
doit être les premiers
bénéficiaires de nos mesures c'est ceux
qui subissent le plus le dérèglement
climatique il morphle les pollutions le
dérèglement climatique le chaos mais ça
doit être les premiers bénéficiaires
quand vous isolez un logement quand vous
faites des transports collectifs quand
vous assurez que là où il y a pas de
transport collectif il y a une voiture
qui est pas chère et pas des SUV à 70000
balles tout ça c'est participer du mieux
vivre ensemble aussi ça va bientôt être
la fin de de l'émission
le programme d'Idy soves pour les mois
qui viennent il s'établit comment déjà
COP 28 ouis ouais donc COP 28 pendant
les prochaines semaines on ESS donc là
relation avec des responsables
politiques à nouveau des déciseurs c'est
ça on va essayer de faire faire bouger
des choses et malgré le fait voilà a une
magnifique moi je l'ai vu à Glasgow
exposition justement sur sur tous les
enjeux de la glace et c'est c'est
passionnant ex c'est ça elle se balade
cette exposition alors elle se balade
surtout au COP en ce moment on essaie de
faire bouger les les d mettre dans les
villes je suis d'accord vous avez raison
fa faut que chacun puisse y
accéderducation ouais bah en parlant
d'éducation je retourne auvalb justement
donner des cours à l'université faut
quand même que je retrouve mes mes
étudiants de temps en temps et puis
ensuite toujours en en préparation de
prochaines expéditions voilà que ce soit
sur les glaciers tropicaux on essaie
avec mes équipes de partir en Afrique de
l'Est là où les glaciers sont la source
la plus haute et la plus permanente d'
île donc on se rend compte que leur
importance elle se voit sur des des
centaines voir des milliers de
kilomètres ça se trouve où en Afrique de
l'Est alors ça se trouve en Uganda ouais
exactement les glaciers des mondes et
renzori ça s'appelle et le kilim Jaro
c'est quoi son expériance de vie c'est
compliqué c'est le problème du
Kilimanjaro c'est lié en grande partie à
la déforestationou au-delà du changement
climatique de la montagne donc il y a
encore beaucoup de choses qu'on peut
faire pour les glaciers et vraiment
l'objectif dans tout ce que je fais
c'est de continuer à sensibiliser de
parler avec le cœur mais de faire en
sorte que tout le monde comprenne à quel
point ces glaciers on en a bien besoin
avec cette formidable lettre glacier que
vous avez écrite j'imagine de votre de
votre main cité avec votre voix dans
dans le documentaire que que nous avons
vu à l'occasion de cette émission un
grand merci vraiment à tous les deux he
d'avoir participé à ce Badoc vos
réactions ça sera sur hashtag debadoc
alors là à mon avis c'est à espérer
j'espère qu'il y aura beaucoup de
réactions et vous serez là d'ailleurs
pour réagir à ce qu'elles seront ces
réaction merci à
selmaali chez nous aussi hein exactement
c'est les Alpes et les Pyrénées vous
avez raison le citer qui m'ont aidé à
préparer cette émission prochain
rendez-vous avec desbadoc ça sera ici
même même place même heure et toujours
avec son documentaire et son débat à
très
[Musique]
bientôt